I've talked about this before,...
...but think about how frustrating that feeling of not getting anything done is.
Oftentimes, this is just a result of constantly disrupting your focus,...
...because of notifications, which is very unnatural.
And second, this mainly applies to Instagram,...
...but I went ahead and kind of diluted my feed.
I went ahead and followed about 20 accounts or hashtags...
...that are run by complete strangers to me.
These are all accounts that post, like, eye candy, but without any context.
I find that these photos, although they're very pretty, often kind of blend together...
...and they make scrolling through Instagram a lot more repetitive...
...and far less addictive.
I'm kind of like, why am I looking at this right now?
I have better things to do, and I get off.
The only way that any of this is gonna work for you...
...is if you have some level of accountability and desire to change,...
...which I'm guessing you already do since you're watching this video.
The cool thing about this is that it snowballs.
So, at first, the changes might feel difficult and clunky, but it gets easier.
Just starting the process can really lead you to cleaning things up,...
...and being a little bit healthier on social media.